I know you're listening there's this kid
he needs our help let's do this
this'll be fun
[Music]
I like this guy Oh give him a chance
all right so does this kid he's in
trouble he needs do kids give us a
chance to be better than you stupid guy
daddy's got this
maybe your best shot what I Willy
forty
[Laughter]
hey everybody we got a whole bunch of
your Deadpool to break down and I have a
ticket giveaway for infinity war that is
like Willy Wonka level crazy it's for a
marathon on a Wednesday that I'll
explain they are working in some deep
cuts to this Deadpool trailer most of
you are probably thinking about that
Alpha Flight Easter egg on top of the
taxicab that dopinder is driving like
wait a minute what's going on here if
you don't know who Alpha Flight is there
another Canadian team Wolverine was part
of them for a while Ryan Reynolds's
Canadian the Deadpool character is
Canadian so there's just a lot of Canada
jokes in the Deadpool franchise you get
a little more footage of the recruitment
it even looks like there's a poster of
outlaw outside the door to this room
that they're in here so if you don't
know who outlaw is she's just a female
character that appears during the
Deadpool series very notable for some of
her physical attributes but her name is
anneza temple I don't necessarily think
that she's gonna be a character in any
of these movies but they might reference
her in some funny way you get a much
better idea for what the timeline is of
him recruiting his x-force team so you
have Colossus negasonic teenage warhead
and Serge here who already at the
x-mansion just probably legit x-men
members that he tries to go co-op so he
does his John Cusack say anything with a
tiny little mp3 boombox Ryan Reynolds
said that there were a lot of little
moments like this referencing some of
their favorite films from their
childhood but say anything it's just
something that winds up getting parodied
in almost every TV show in every movie
at some point a little more the crayon
drawings from the first movie him just
drawing what their plan is for this big
convoy heist where he fights cable later
then right after this one-eyed Willy
joke you can spot where they're swapping
jokes trying to punch up the movie
remember Deadpool's mouth is covered so
they can actually swap in a lot of
different jokes if they think that they
find something that's funnier him making
a joke about turning 40 and slowing down
is Ryan Reynolds making fun of himself
when the first movie came out he was 39
getting ready to turn 40 so now he's
like oh I'm over the hill getting too
old I mean you talk about old
superheroes if you ever wonder if
there's life after 40 for some of these
action stars just watch Hugh Jackman
working out for the Logan movie like
right now he's getting ready to turn
50 he was still well into his late 40s
when he was working out for the Logan
movie it is nuts we just buy a lot of
times in successive sequels you'll see
that they find ways to not go shirtless
like Ryan Reynolds is still relatively
young but Robert Downey jr. stays fit
it's not like he has to say super ripped
when was the last time you saw Iron Man
in a movie with his shirt off like it's
been a long time Ryan Reynolds also gave
a new synopsis with all this new
material they dropped he said Wade has
settled into his new life and looks
settled into everything else in
particular his relationship in a pretty
positive way but also he's a victim of
his own hubris once we start the movie
and that's sort of what creates
conflicts in the issues that he has to
deal with main conflict this time is a
time traveler who's come back from the
future because of a superpower teen
Russell they both have their competing
agendas one is to capture the kid in one
is to save the kid he's valuable to both
of them in different ways and it becomes
personal for both of them so the
interesting thing is like we think the
cable is trying to kill the Russell
character Russell Collins aka fire fist
I think we've all pretty much landed on
him but when they say capture the kid it
sounds like there might be something a
little bit deeper going on I'm not
expecting them to go straight to strife
Mutant Liberation Front but like I said
during my last big trailer video that's
kind of where the russell collins
character goes so i don't know what else
they would be leading up to if they
weren't leading up to Mutant Liberation
Front in this post-apocalyptic world so
the other big part of this is everybody
has now discovered Peter just like the
totally normal dude like your lame dad
joins x-force he has the most
delightfully funny Twitter account you
can kind of tell just from some of these
tweets like is this building towards
some sort of bit are they trying to
develop some backstory and then kill him
off in a hilarious way during the movie
is it gonna be something deeper are they
turning him into the new Hydra Bob
because Hydra Bob's personality is a
little bit like Peters and there was a
Hydra Bob during the first movie but
because Hydra Bob is technically a
Marvel character they couldn't do
straight-up Hydra Bob they had to find
like a funny way to do it but when he's
talking to this guy here in this scene
this is supposed to be the Hydra Bob
from the Deadpool comics
wait oh my god I would seen you since
Jacksonville TGI Fridays come here you
how are the kids good Gail she still
fixing that tuna casserole so good I
think what's going on with Peter is that
he's meant to be more of a long play to
make the movie a little more relatable
and a little more hilarious and a joke
on the idea of these big super team ups
because Deadpool is making fun of
himself but it's also making fun of big
superhero team-up movies like the dude
right off the street joins the team and
it becomes this hilarious thing like
wait a minute is even skilled enough to
do this how's this gonna go down you
don't really see any footage of him
after they jump out of the back of this
plane here and I know it kind of seems
like they're jumping out of the back of
the plane to invade the facility but I
think they're jumping out of the plane
to attack the convoy the convoy then
eventually makes it to the facility it
would be kind of funny if they created a
new Hydra Bob within this universe they
didn't kill him up so that they can
bring him back during the x-force movie
and do that Hydra bob style scene and
it'll be a little more meaningful like
oh yeah you remember just like the
totally normal regular guy while his
crazy stuff is going on but when Ryan
Reynolds says the Deadpool creates a lot
of the conflict himself because of his
hubris in the movie that probably has
something to do with the creation of the
x-force team like usually he thinks he
can do stuff by himself but then he
fails then he has to create the super
duper group but cable is trying to save
the future even though he's trying to
kill this kid so technically he's not
the villain of the movie even though
he's the antagonist of all these
trailers because Deadpool is trying to
save the kid so let me know in the
comments if you spotted any other Easter
eggs in the backgrounds of these
trailers they'll probably see some more
of this as we get past infinity war I
don't know if they're gonna drop any new
Deadpool next week because it really is
infinity war week just to explain that
Willy Wonka infinity war ticket giveaway
what's happening is is the El Capitan in
Los Angeles is hosting a marathon
starting on Wednesday ending on Thursday
the last film is infinity war so you
watched 12 films building up to infinity
war pretty standard situation
it comes with food it's for one ticket
though you have to be able to physically
meet me at the theater so I can hand you
a ticket in the vouchers for all the
food myself so that's gonna be on
Wednesday so if you think you can make
that that just let me know in the
comments I just say I'm a Los Angeles
person or I live nearby and I can make
the marathon I'll name the winner when I
post my Westworld episode 1 video on
Sunday night so don't worry like if you
can't make this marathon and you're
bummed out I'm still doing the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway in all the Marvel
videos but no worries like I said all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave that comment
letting me know that you're a Los
Angeles person on the video if you're a
big fan of The Witcher video game series
they just announced a bunch of details
about the Netflix live-action adaptation
so I'm gonna do video for that next
there'll be new infinity war this
weekend too so no worries while you wait
for everything click here for brand new
infinity war and click here for that
other Deadpool trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]